jennifer lopez and ben affleck spotted
house hunting in los angeles
it's the best time it's the best time of
my life the pair may not be moving in
together
just yet but they were out and about on
thursday in
la's upscale neighborhood of holmby
hills checking out an expansive 31 000
square foot home
that boasts 8 bedrooms and 12 bathrooms
and plenty of room for them
and their own children feels really good
and it's really nice but i'm
so happy you know what i mean if jen
nabs the house her 13 year old twins
with ex mark anthony
max and emmy and ben's three children
with ex jen garner
violet seraphina and samuel will get to
enjoy
a bowling alley movie theater an in-home
hair salon
and two massive pools it was incredible
i've never seen
anything like it the mansion's price tag
over 60 million
ben and jen were reportedly escorted to
the home by a high-end realtor
and the couple shared a sweet kiss
before heading inside the home
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
the 51 year old singer and the 48 year
old actor
spent about half an hour touring the
property before heading off to see
another
yeah i'm ready i'm excited about it the
house hunting news
comes after a source told et earlier
this month that
friends wouldn't be surprised if they
move in together and ultimately end up
together you guys want to get used to
seeing us again
let's hope so benefit 2.0 has made their
relationship a family affair
as the two have been nearly inseparable
since they linked up earlier this year
spending time together in montana miami
and the hamptons often with their kids
in tow
e.t source says the pair's relationship
is quote not a big deal
to either sets of kids adding they
aren't super sensitive to the situation
sometimes you have to change direction
even though
that might be painful or it might be you
know
seem weird to other people it's really
just about who you are and what feels
right to you
ben and jen seem better than ever almost
18 years post split
the couple who fans dubbed benefer in
the early 2000s
were previously engaged from 2002 to
2004.
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just
a bad heartbreak like you know just one
of those breakups that really
you know it was like a tough one for me
for whatever reason
the source adds when ben reached out to
j.lo she was really excited at the
possibility of them rekindling their
relationship
j lo has always had a love for ben back
in the day ben broke up with jlo
because he was overwhelmed by the
constant media attention and fame
that the relationship brought but now
they are in an amazing place and they
have really learned what works for them
as a couple i'm great on my own and i
think once you
get to that place then amazing things
happen to you
that you would never imagine in your
life happening
again